T'es con... J'aime pas faire ça. Salut !
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis toujours à l'entrepôt à Mulhouse dans le théâtre de mademoiselle Sarah Marguier.
Bonjour.
Aujourd'hui on est dimanche et le dimanche c'est le jour des astuces.
Donc je vais vous donner une astuce pour pouvoir bluffler vos amis  et les mentaliser à votre tour.
J'ai réfléchi à un petit truc pour que vous puissiez forcer psychologiquement quelqu'un à choisir l'objet que vous voulez.
En l'occurence une pièce de monnaie.
Je vais le faire avec vous depuis la caméra. Néanmoins il y a de fortes chances que ça ne marche pas
comme ça à travers la vidéo. J'ai jamais essayé de le faire comme ça en travers vidéo.
Mais je pense pas que ce soit tout à fait possible parce que il n'y a pas les pièces devant nous  mais
ça servira quand même de démonstration comme ça vous aurez tout le script pour pouvoir après le refaire.
Soyez bien avec moi, soyez bien concentrés. Imaginez  que devant vous
il y a 3 pièces de monnaie.
Une pièce de 2€, une pièce de 1€ et une pièce d'un centime d'euro.
Dans quelques instants vous allez choisir une pièce et vous aurez le sentiment que ce sera le bon choix.
Il y a trois possibilités, il y a par exemple la pièce de 2€  vous pourriez choisir celle ci simplement parce que
c'est celle qui a le plus de valeur financièrement.
Mais il y a également le pièce de 1€, elle est très intéressante parce qu'elle est un peu plus petite
et pourtant elle a de la dorure autour. Et cette dorure est très attirante visuellement.
Un petit peu comme si c'était  de l'or, et de l'argent au coeur.
Et enfin il y a l'autre pièce. Ca c'est un peu drôle mon grand père disait toujours le centime c'est le début de la fortune.
Quand je claquerai des doigts vous allez choisir une des trois pièces et vous aurez le sentiment maintenant d'avoir fait le bon choix.
Le choix qu'il fallait faire.
Allez y.  Maintenant. *clap*
Je vais vous dire quelle pièce vous devez avoir dans la main.
Encore une fois si ça n'a pas marché ne vous inquiétez pas c'est pas bien grave.
Je pense qu'en vidéo c'est plus dur à gérer. Si on n'a pas les objets physiques que je puisse vous les faire voir au fur et à mesure
La pièce que vous devez avoir c'est le centime. Si c'est le cas alors la mentalisation s'est bien passée même à travers la vidéo.
Si c'est pas le cas, c'est tout à fait normal.
Néanmoins vous si vous répétez le même script  en le faisant à quelqu'un vous allez réussir.
Et voici pourquoi
Il faut prendre le temps, il faut que la personne soit concentrée il faut mettre les pièces dans cet ordre là
le 2€  le plus gros,  le 1€ et ensuite le centime.
Répétez tout le script comme je l'ai dit. Mot à mot. C'est essentiel.
Ce que je dis sur la pièce de 2€. Sur la pièce de 1€  et sur l'autre, je nomme pas le centime.
C'est un sens très précis. Le fait de rajouter un affect avec l'histoire de mon grand père sur le centime
ça a aussi un but de forçage. La dernière phrase que je dis "vous aurez le sentiment maintenant d'avoir fait le bon choix"
C'est pas une phrase au hasard. Si vous écoutez bien j'ai dit exactement  " vous aurez le centime en main"
"Vous aurez le sentiment maintenant d'avoir fait le bon choix"
C'est une petite influence en plus. Et c'est l'ensemble de tout ça qui va faire que la personne lorsque que vous claquerez des doigts
choisira le centime.
Prenez le temps de bien l'apprendre. Répétez le un petit peu. Faites en sorte de l'avoir au mot à mot  exactement.
Et amusez vous dès ce dimanche ou cette semaine à bluffler vos amis en faisant ça
Vous allez voir vous allez avoir un très gros taux de réussite de l'ordre de 90%
Malheureusement comme toutes les influences elles ne peuvent pas marcher non plus dans 100% des cas
C'était une explication un petit peu différente de celles qu'on fait d'habitude
J'espère que ça vous a plu. Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en mettant un petit
POUCE EN L'AIR !
N'oubliez pas de commenter la vidéo, je lis tous vos commentaires et j'y réponds la majeure partie du temps
pas toujours dans l'instant mais je réponds toujours dans le temps.
Merci à tous ceux qui sont venus me voir à Mulhouse à l'entrepôt  durant ces 3 jours
N'oubliez pas aussi de vous abonner à la chaîne. Passez un excellent dimanche.
Et rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog.  Ciao !
Ciao.